so far in this series you've queried
data stored within bigquery by following
a common path of ingesting your data
storing it and then analyzing it but
it's also possible to query data stored
externally or outside of bigquery
in today's episode of bigquery spotlight
we're diving in
to these external data sources
[Music]
wait so the world exists outside of
bigquery
of course it does the good news is that
it's possible to leave your data in
place
and use bigquery as your query engine we
call these sources external or federated
data sources
this functionality is currently
supported for data residing in google
drive
cloud storage cloud sql and bigtable
before we look closer at how to query
these sources
let's discuss a few notable differences
you'll experience with external data
sources
first to note is that the query
performance for external data sources
may not equal the query performance of
data stored in bigquery
so if query speed is a priority in your
case you may want to load the data
directly into bigquery
secondly when querying an external
source bigquery cannot predict the
amount of data to be processed
so you will only know after you run your
query finally
the results are not cached like they
would be when querying data stored in
bigquery
caching is a great way to save costs and
improve performance on repeated queries
when the underlying data hasn't changed
so given these considerations what are
some popular use cases for external data
sources
overall this feature is best for
short-term less frequently accessed data
for example you could use external data
sources to support loading and
transforming your data in just a single
pass
in this workflow you query the external
source transform the data as part of the
query
and then write the results as a
permanent table in bigquery storage
another use case is for joining small
amounts of frequently changing data with
data stored in bigquery
by keeping the frequently changing data
as an external data source
it does not need to be reloaded into
bigquery every time it is updated
an example here is querying data that
lives in a google sheet
even as the sheet is edited in real time
you can run
queries over the data and the results
will reflect the live
up-to-date information okay so now let's
look at the how for setting up external
data sources
in bigquery you can follow along in your
own bigquery sandbox
if you don't have one yet set one up
following the video link below
in this example you'll run a query over
a collection of json files located in a
cloud storage bucket
these files have the flight performance
data for all domestic flights in the
united states from 2014
starting in the console create a new
data set highlight your project name in
the left-hand nav
and click create data set name the data
set flight underscore performance
choose us for the location and click
create data set
now highlight your new data set and
click create table
under source choose google cloud storage
quick note if your data was located in
google drive
such as in a google sheet or in bigtable
you would choose those alternate sources
in the dropdown
the flight performance data is located
in a public bucket which any gcp user
can access with the uri
address paste the uri provided in the
description below into the gcs bucket
field
you'll see there's a wildcard character
in the uri which indicates to bigquery
to include all the json files that
adhere to the specific naming convention
next under destination make sure you set
the table type to external
name the table 2014
and you can auto detect the schema in
this case
finally click create table since there
is no data ingestion involved you'll see
the table immediately populate under the
data set
look at the table details where you can
see the external configuration that you
just set up
and a table size of zero bytes because
your external table does not use any
bigquery storage
now you can run a query that references
the external table
in our query we're selecting account of
all flights by carrier as we discussed
earlier you cannot see the amount of
data processed until after the query
completes
in this example you created a permanent
table for the external data source
however you can also query an external
source using a temporary table
which is useful for one-time ad-hoc
queries or for etl processes
more information on how to create and
query temporary external tables is
linked below
want to analyze data in cloud sql
creating the initial connection follows
a different process than you just saw
for cloud storage and drive
but never fear we've created a quick
start video linked below that shows you
end to end how to connect to and
query your mysql or postgres instance in
cloud sql
looking to data sources beyond the
google cloud ecosystem
we recently announced bigquery omni
which gives bigquery users the ability
to analyze data stored in other public
clouds
be sure to check out the announcement
blog post link below
thanks for joining us today for bigquery
spotlight watch out for our next episode
and remember
stay curious
[Music]
you